sin acuerdos así concluyó la reunión
entre el presidente iván duque y el
comité organizador del paro que expuso
al mandatario su amplio pliego de
peticiones de emergencia tanto
económicas como sociales que datan de
las masivas marchas de 2019 y que buscan
soluciones a la crisis política y social
que ha causado las protestas y que se ha
visto agravada por la pandemia de kobe
19 la retirada de la fallida reforma
tributaria del gobierno ha dado paso a
otras exigencias abanderadas por una
renta básica de emergencia para 6
millones de hogares en condición de
pobreza y vulnerabilidad por un período
de seis meses las propuestas tendrían un
costo aproximado de 81 billones de pesos
anuales según cálculos de economistas
locales la mayoría casi 74 billones
destinados a la renta básica por ello
los expertos dudan de la viabilidad para
llevar a cabo unas propuestas económicas
tan ambiciosas a la luz de la situación
fiscal del país con el 49 2% de la
población trabajando en la informalidad
y más del 42 por ciento en situación de
pobreza si en el presupuesto del comité
está muy por encima de la fallida
reforma tributaria de casi 25 billones
de pesos colombianos
el comité difiere del gobierno
economistas tradicionales en la forma de
recaudar los fondos para estas ayudas
sociales proponen que la banca central
haga préstamos la monetización de las
reservas internacionales impuestos a los
más ricos o una apuesta por la
producción nacional